[Music]
well we are counting down the hours to
Puerto Rican the view of the hit
Broadway musical Hamilton it's part of
an effort to raise money and awareness
for the u.s. territory after Hurricane
Maria devastated the island in 2017
creator lin-manuel Miranda will play the
role he developed Alexander Hamilton
he's brought the Tony award-winning show
to the island where his parents were
born David beg no is with us again from
Dorado beach Puerto Rico he takes us
behind the scenes before tonight's big
show David I know you're very excited to
be back there you're almost as famous in
Puerto Rico as lin-manuel is listen we
were so excited to see him last night
beyond I got to tell you you know since
Hurricane Maria Puerto Rico is declared
they are open for business they want you
to come and sit on the beach they want
you to see the natural wonders and
people here like the folks who've come
to actually see Lin they think that Lin
bringing Hamilton here puts the island
in the spotlight the limelight and gives
it the positive press it needs every
dollar for every ticket sold will go to
the Arts on the island and I got to tell
you last night when Lin Manuel took the
stage in San Juan it was glorious what a
moment twenty-one seconds of applause
for lin-manuel Miranda
as he took the stage for the final dress
rehearsal of Hamilton last night when
the show ended we noticed two words he
yelled the thirty-eight-year-old Miranda
and cast are performing in San Juan at
the Centro de Bay us out of taste good
[Music]
thank you sir
there's our list of actors that are in
the show where's the rick mcgraw order
so here you are having grown up on the
island I haven't lived here in 30 years
you know I'd pursue my dreams New York
LA and just to come home and have family
here and see how the island has gone
through an amazing transformation rick
mcgraw on is the only cast member in the
production who was born in Puerto Rico
he plays King George the third so here
we are
nough grande seemed like just the right
person to take us behind the scenes
still you know we're still working here
but there we are
we have odd way in Puerto Rico Broadway
in Puerto Rico exactly this is a nice
place this is a beautiful thing yeah
this is nice
it wasn't the first choice the musical
was supposed to be put on at the
University of Puerto Rico that is the
alma mater of Luis Miranda who is Lynne
Manuel's father the island and
particularly the University have gone
through so much turmoil change economic
austerity that I figured let's put them
on the map but after a million dollars
was spent to repair the University's
theater a local labor union sent a
warning the letter ended up saying there
are real problems at the University of
Puerto Rico and we want to advise bad
things protests can happen around your
production and you're thinking I don't
know if I can provide security for
everybody who's coming to see the
musical yeah you know we have 1700
people inside that theater right we have
150 cast and
including my son what do you want
this production to mean to the island
puerto rico is ready that if this can
happen tonnes of all the things can
happen Congress can keep went Oh Rico
the aid it needs and when push comes to
shove back at the theater with the king
he introduced us to Vincent Hooper who's
from Austin Texas aside from those moves
he covers six roles in the musical
Hamilton is his first major production
being a young black men are there are
only so many shows I think that that
really give you the chance to stretch
yourself this much and and to dig in
this much at any given moment how many
people are doing a costume change behind
the scenes oh my god at some points you
have almost the entire cast ensemble and
principles changing how about your
outfit are you ready
it's I'm the king and this is the piece
de resistance oh boy look at this that
is my cape once I have that puppy on in
the crown there's only one way to walk
and it's a regal a regal cape for a
regal set that arrived by boat from New
York City and they even let a commoner
try out the cage for a millisecond how's
it feel good I feel like Gill King would
look better in this yeah I definitely
was not meant to be royalty you know
with the tickets they sold some of them
for $5,000 they wanted wealthy people to
come to the island but they have also
kept ten thousand tickets that they're
selling for $10 a piece who's going
you're going one two three four five
okay that's good six people in fact we
heard that there may be some celebs
there Jimmy Buffett Shonda Rhimes maybe
the Clintons and I heard Oprah Gayle I
was thinking you might be able to help
us confirm it that is absolutely true
absolutely true David I was always
debating should I say should I not say
but that's absolutely true she is coming
excellent I don't think she plan to
announce it but just can't lie on TV at
ly I get Dell a lot but David what a
great piece it's bringing up so many
memories just hearing the music that's
really really wonderful what you're
doing there I can't wait Porto Rico
deserves all the positive press we can
guess you're absolutely right about that
thanks a lot